yo what up I'm Sean Smith Straight Out
of Philly rapping saying could swim The
Hope dealer the hottest rapper out
filming
um yeah I hope de la EP coming out
probably like a couple weeks next week
we say
coming out soon but I'm gonna be
dropping all year and for the rest of
life so make sure I get with me sink and
swim Sean Smith let's get it
yeah
[Applause]
let's go
yo yo
yo
rocking Prada but [__] them [__] who
redlined us I want a story where the
ending ain't the feds find us stand up
[__] they folded behind me like the
seated assemblies silly me can't see it
was Envy we ever see a lightning ends we
take charge the city where they touch a
lot of arms like Ray Charles Jake
popping up like Good Neighbors at State
Farm leaving candlelights with a flesh
wound dogs get turned to balloons sort
of like Jeff Coons laws get turned in
the news in order to stretch rules Blood
On The Leaves he bled out alone the Nina
was singing he let our simones heater
was banging he bled out his Dome [__]
better stay inside their place like
quarantine I come to town with different
Jeeps bodied up huge tankers up and down
with Bittersweet without these get two
fingers juggle around within discreet
and find him in true danger my brother's
down there lifted piece behind me like
news angers any room I stepping on my
obvious mood changing treated like my
strap spray that he talked to come fly
the leader other packs made back we all
alumni flee with all the cats ASAP be
charging dumb High Leonardo dicap great
can't see hard to come by uh yo yo yeah
I ain't got a thug story I ain't got a
drug Story Probably with the plug shorty
keep my faith me and mine hit up quote
for some input like HDMI tell me what a
session I probably pull up go off
people's elbow it ain't [__] to pull off
a boat guard all we know is go hard till
they stamp us like postcards landed back
in Philly homesick but that he must have
missed well everything the same except
the ones I used to bust it with token of
advice get a ticket take a couple trips
[__] pulling strings the back door you
want some sucker [__] leave them when I
shake so you know we playing that on
this game hands in a lot of things bada
bang rotors Arthur BG's but we coming
out wise like Rihanna's name mine don't
know money we ain't tired of Fame had to
see my broken ties with open eyes take a
step back to see the truth because
emotions lie The Jokers is called in the
link the feature might cost you the bank
I had these hating [__] Alec Baldwin
that's drawing the blank [__] like me
too hard to be hated they lost to the
thing should I took our soul from us see
a lot of cold summers so I paint
pictures of my street like I'm the
Roadrunner [__] can't go through it
even if they tried they disappear even
if they die yeah yeah
I told him if I dropped this [__] I
gotta be classic I'm taking matters in
my own hand like pottery classes I do
advise you [__] give me my flowers had
to make plates and really forced my hand
to let it take shape [__] spun me till
I'm something that they can eat off Bo
do you [__] dishing out of ice when we
don't need y'all and on their way down
they wanna bro together all cool they
never split the wave when they had Moses
level walkthroughs with a young guy I
just wanna be a voice take a swim so
[__] know they got the luxury of
choice yeah I said Sean Smith sink and
swim Straight Out of Philly hope dealer
hey I know you just watched a new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off in checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week